a group of frantic parents calling
police and tracking a school bus after
they claimed the driver was speeding and
driving erratically now they shot the
video that you're about to see and it's
the latest in a series of confrontations
between parents and ccsd drivers madison
kimbrough in the newsroom with a story
you'll only see on 8.
parents of bonner elementary say
monday's afternoon's bus chase was
beyond anything they've ever experienced
and recall their kids screaming on the
phone asking the bus driver to pull over
and take them home
aisha butler is one of a handful of
parents who pulled their child off of a
school bus monday after they felt the
driver was unsafe the bus speeds past me
i mean had it clearly be going at least
60 miles an hour light turns yellow as
we're there light turns red bus barrels
through the red light kids were late
coming home from bonner elementary
school and the bus tracking app couldn't
locate them butler's granddaughter was
on board she calls my phone she says
nana
he looks like he's about to get on the
freeway the bus driver is going the
wrong way where is he going
[Music]
in this case a metro officer checked on
the kids and deemed the driver safe to
finish the route but earlier incidents
between family members and drivers have
turned violent
less than two weeks ago clark county
school district reported two separate
incidents of attacks on bus drivers the
first happening august 17 in the
afternoon on boulder highway and russell
road the second the following morning
near tonopah highway and vegas drive
parents like mark daffron don't agree
with the violence but simply want to be
diligent about safety we wanted to make
sure that he wasn't going to continue on
his way with the 20 remaining children
whose parents were probably worried sick
now we reached out to ccsd about this
incident but haven't heard back and
according to the parents we spoke to the
same bus driver was on the same route
again today in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now